The Joe Rogan Experience like John Daly
you know he's a gifted athlete you know
and he would no matter what he' have
done he would have been great at it uh
but he chose to do it with golf and and
his situation at home was real up
abusive father horrible just
horrible I know a lot about him
I've spent a lot of nights drinking with
him and uh but he had these hands man
and this this ability to turn his back
to his Target and just keep going and it
generated literally no one had ever seen
anybody do what John Daly did when he
first started hit when he first came on
the scene they the other Pros were going
out to the driving rigns going watch
this and he's hitting the ball 75 yards
past everybody and hit in the middle of
the Fairway with it they're like and but
he was so
self-destructive that he he he couldn't
he he could manage it till some point
you know I don't know and John doesn't
know either I'm sure but you know he won
two majors which you know most people
that play professional golf or never win
one and or never win a tournament that
most people that have a card to play on
the PGA tour never win on the PGA tour
so he didn't do earth shattering stuff
like tiger did as far as the numbers go
but you know he he just had that natural
ability and and and his son is just like
him which is kind of a weird thing
because that fatherson thing doesn't
mesh up then who knows if It ultimately
will but his son's got a pocket full of
money Bets with everybody there he's
about 16 no he's in college now so he's
quite a player and he's got his dad's
back swing and you know it's uh damn so
it's genetic well some of some of it's
got to be you know yeah and then you man
I would imagine yeah there he is right
there imagine that's who I play with
belts yeah that they won the
father ton son tournament they beat
tiger and his kid bro how great are John
dy's pants yeah look at those pants
those are so classic yep and you can uh
skulls all over them
yeah those green alligator shoes he
awesome he's one of a kind that's for
sure one of a kind One of a Kind how
many D Co do you say he drinks a day he
well he drinks boy he just drinks so
much uh but he drinks Diet Cokes and
chocolate milk and he doesn't really eat
and then he drinks vodka by the galab
and you know chocolate chocolate milk if
you go cuz we the look at him we I've
stayed in the same house with him before
and he's also oddly enough he's a neat
freak he gets up in the morning and
he'll make breakfast for everybody
that's in the you know the golf
complex there like four four rooms or
whatever he's up in the morning
vacuuming shining stuff up not even his
job to do it and but he's a neat freak
and he loves to cook for people and and
at night he'll sing songs and play
guitar until you're so bored with it you
can't stand yourself and uh you know but
it's a hoot it's a show but in the
refrigerator Ator gallons of milk in a
chocolate a Hershey's chocolate squirt
bottle he makes it up himself you know
and uh he makes his own chocolate he
stirs it and then Diet Cokes and then
cigarettes you know one after another
pull that back up Jamie with that the
statistics that you were showing the
statistics he was just showing about how
many cigarettes and Diet Cokes he drank
in one game this this say is a daily
diet I don't know yeah but that one
image that you had on the other page
there was a you had
it there it is John Daly smoked 21
cigarettes and drank 12 cans of coke and
no water at a PGA Tour event John Daly
once smoked 21 cigarettes and drank 12
cans of coke at a Tour event with no
water the controversial golfer is known
among fans for a somewhat different
style to to Today's Fitness obsessed
Stars so if he drank 12 coca colas
though you do have to think like that is
a lot of energy and a lot of yeah and
and this guy doesn't
practice ever at golf he doesn't no
he'll go out there and he'll hit sand
wedges uh and he'll hit maybe four of
them and uh and go straight to the tea
box whether he's playing a professional
Tour event or playing with ay but and he
tells me just hit some sandwich you got
to hit that if you can hit that solid
you can hit them all solid just do that
there's no say working your way through
a bag and spending all goddamn day you
know just get cuz that you're trying to
get loose not better we're playing right
you don't have time to get better you
just got time to get loose get loose
with one Club so but uh it it he uh but
that's just how much ability he's got
most of these guys you know they take
this serious every goddamn day of
their life hours and hours hours a day
go into nothing but preparing he spends
no time at all and uh and he he doesn't
win very much but you know he makes a
lot of noise and he he lives life the
way he wants to and he's so unap
apologetic and you know and he's kind of
a hero because of it he is yeah yeah
he's he's totally a hero and he should
be he he is a living legend of of
athletic superiority and there
he is Hooters there's his endorsement
right there he loves
Hooters yeah for years and years I'd go
to the Masters and I'd Park my bus right
next to his bus at the Hooters and uh
and
hilarious uh and go down and watch the
game and and he would make Fortune
because people go to that tournament to
see golf right and uh but those golf
those guys aren't available you know
they don't come they don't stick around
signning autographs and do like
that John does so he's got a merch tent
set up at the Hooters and he'll do
$400,000 worth of business in a week
just sitting there signing stuff Flags
whatever taking pictures he hustles that
parking lot and uh does it every year
he's always out there he'll you know
he's nice anyway and uh he likes fans
and he'll talk to you about anything
anybody and uh you know if he's in a
good mood if he's in a shitty mood maybe
not but he still gets it you know and uh
because he didn't he gambles a lot so he
never has I don't think ever had a big
surplus of money had some big deals from
Callaway and but I think he you know
he's playing slot machines a th000 bucks
a pull all the time and uh so he's
always had to hustle on the side you
know so but he but he gets it done you
know now he's got a vodka drink kind of
like the arm Palmer except it's got
booze in it's called John Daly selling
out of it yeah what is the John
Daly what's the mixture honor Palmer is
uh lemonade and iced tea right I think
then you had some vodka I imagine is
that what is John D yeah y yep Voda
yeah yeah him and you know I I quit
drinking you know that about three years
ago and and uh but and Kid Rock hangs
out there all the time and they're
really good buddies and he plays golf
it's just not a Great Golf Course either
it's just as one we all go to and uh you
know it's got good greens and we had fun
time out there and they'll be banging on
the door my bus we're going to the ttty
bar come
go what part of if I don't drink anymore
do you not understand I'm know I'm not
going to the titty bar with you and Kid
Rock and watch you guys jack was
strippers Till Dawn
and hilarious so now they don't talk to
me much and uh they those guys
when they sober up
the part's all gone right that's right
yeah I read something the other day said
if you quit drinking that doesn't
automatically make you no fun that's a
separate
decision